[EU STRATEGY
ON CHILDREN’S RIGHTS]
[CHILD PARTICIPATION
IN POLICY-MAKING]
[30% OF THE WORLD POPULATION
ARE CHILDREN]
We do not want to keep
growing up in a society
where profit is more important
than helping one another.
Children want to be heard.
[COMBATING VIOLENCE]
[50% OF CHILDREN WORLDWIDE
ARE VICTIMS OF VIOLENCE]
I was five years old
when the conflict first started.
The airstrikes started
hitting our area
and we would not go outside
due to the fierce bombing.
[ONLINE PROTECTION]
[27% OF CHILDREN IN THE EU EXPERIENCE
DISTURBING CONTENT ONLINE ONCE A MONTH]
For me bullying is an act of physical,
psychological or verbal violence.
We have to understand
that these types of situations
are more and more frequent nowadays
and that is of a great concern.
[CHILD FRIENDLY JUSTICE]
[33% OF ASYLUM APPLICATIONS
TO THE EU IN 2020 WERE CHILDREN]
[SOCIO-ECONOMIC INCLUSION]
[22% OF CHILDREN IN THE EU ARE AT RISK
OF POVERTY OR SOCIAL EXCLUSION]
Children do not just want to survive,
they want to live,
they want to thrive.
We want not to be judged
by our age, our sexuality, our ethnicity,
but by the beauty of our dreams.
[GLOBAL DIMENSION]
[10% OF CHILDREN WORLDWIDE
ARE FORCED INTO LABOUR]
Hardly a day passes without
a child being abused.
Children given out for child labour
are seen in the streets,
having no place
to lay their heads.
It is my heart’s desire
that all of this will come to an end
and we will achieve a world
free of violence and harm to children.
Thank you.
[EU STRATEGY
ON CHILDREN’S RIGHTS]
[SPECIALTHANKS
TO THE WORLD VISION]
[AND ALL THE CHILDREN
WHO MADE THIS VIDEO POSSIBLE]